Marvel Comics hasn't always been as big as
it is today, and not all of the company's
history is as heroic as the adventures of
Spider-Man or Captain America.
Since starting out as Timely Comics in 1939,
they've created countless classics, but they've
also done a few things they probably wish
we'd forget.
Here are a few of Marvel's biggest missteps.
Atlas distribution disaster
Back in the 1950s when Marvel was still called
Atlas Comics, publisher Martin Goodman decided
to outsource distribution.
One problem: the distribution company almost
immediately went bankrupt, leaving Goodman
no option but to ask arch-rival DC to distribute
his books.
DC put the screws to Atlas, limiting them
to only eight comics a month—a huge drop
from the 60 or so titles Atlas had previously
published.
Not only did profits plunge, but Atlas had
to fire almost all of their artists and writers.
There was simply nothing for them to do.
Ironically, the company survived because of
an editorial oversight by Stan Lee.
For years, he had been buying too many stories
from his creators, ending up with a closet
full of unpublished comics.
When Atlas imploded, they were able to stay
afloat by finally publishing the issues Stan
had accidentally stockpiled.
Tossing pages
Before comics were seen as collectibles, original
comic art was a means to an end.
It was photographed, colored, printed…and
then the originals were discarded.
While some original pages have been preserved
by collectors, Marvel spent decades simply
chucking countless others, not unlike the
way the BBC tossed dozens of early Doctor
Who episodes.
Today, finding a missing comic page is a victory
for both collectors and comics historians.
Creator mistreatment
It’s a sad fact that while Marvel rakes
in billions of dollars worldwide with their
films, the creators often see little or no
money from it thanks to "work for hire" contracts
that sign all the rights away.
One of the worst examples of Marvel's questionable
treatment of their creators is the case of
Gary Friedrich, the co-creator of Ghost Rider.
After the Ghost Rider movies came out, Friedrich
took Marvel to court for compensation related
to merchandising.
Not only did he lose the lawsuit, Marvel countersued
for $17,000 and forced him to stop selling
anything Ghost Rider-related at conventions.
A judge later overturned the decision and
both parties settled out of court.
Royal Roy
For a period, Marvel Comics also published
Star Comics, a label dedicated to animated
tie-ins like ThunderCats and Fraggle Rock
and other kid-friendly fare.
Part of Star's approach was to copy the success
of Harvey Comics.
They did it a little too well, though.
Royal Roy, a young millionaire, was basically
an exact copy of Harvey's Richie Rich, and
was actually created by an ex-Harvey employee.
Harvey sued Marvel for infringing on their
property, and Royal Roy was canceled after
a handful of issues.
Ron Perelman
In January of 1989, Ron Perelman bought Marvel
for just over $82 million.
He then went full on Wolf of Wall Street,
using Marvel as collateral to leverage the
purchase of other trading card, comic book,
and toy companies...sending the company $700
million into debt.
"Hi yi, hmmmm, hi yi, hmmmm, hmmmm"
By the time Perelman's reign ended, the company
had declared bankruptcy, over a third of its
employees had been laid off, and the entire
comic book industry had collapsed.
And Perelman?
Well, he got rich off of it all, with an estimated
net worth of $14 billion.
Sometimes the supervillains win.
Film Rights
In the early '90s, cash-strapped Marvel raised
capital by signing away the film rights to
pretty much all their characters for pennies
on the dollar.
It seems short-sighted, but it almost makes
sense given that every Marvel film prior to
1998's Blade was a failure.
Don't remember those films?
There's a good reason for that.
First there was the 1990 direct-to-video version
of Captain America, which reported profits
of just over $10,000 on a $10 million budget.
"Holy mackerel"
Then, four years later, the first Fantastic
Four was produced on a shoestring just so
a small movie studio could legally retain
the rights to the characters.
It was so bad, Marvel ended up spending millions
of dollars to keep the film from being distributed
in order to save the brand from being cheapened
by a low-budget flop.
Marvel learned their lesson, though, and in
2004 they formed their own studio and began
buying back the rights to their characters
so they could make the movies themselves.
Seems like that move worked out pretty well.
Marvel's Image
In 1992, several of Marvel's top creators
went to their bosses and asked for a better
deal: more money per page, more royalties
for characters they created, and a more fair
portion of what Marvel was earning off of
their work.
Marvel told them to pound sand.
In response, the artists quit Marvel and formed
their own company: Image Comics.
They became superstars, and Image went on
to revolutionize the industry, while Marvel's
stock dropped so sharply it was featured on
an episode of Moneyline.
Marvel survived, but they could have stayed
ahead of the game—and saved themselves a
lot of trouble—just by playing fair.
Guiding Light
In 2006, Marvel's Editor-in-Chief Joe Quesada
thought it would be a great idea to partner
with, of all companies, Procter & Gamble,
mostly known for selling Pringles, creating
the bowel-loosening food additive Olestra—and
producing the soap opera Guiding Light.
To that end, Guiding Light aired an episode
in which a long-time character was shocked
by some Halloween decorations and briefly
gained superpowers.
Marvel wrote their own version of the story
as a six-page mini-crossover.
The hope was that the cross-promotion would
encourage soap viewers and comics fans to
walk on the other side.
But not many did.
And Guiding Light only lasted a few more years
before it was canceled.
Dang.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Marvel mistake you think was the worst...